[Music]
on this Friday night renewed deadly
aggression on Ukraine Russia's largest
aerial barrage in the war Reigns down on
ukrainians the destructive aftermath as
uncertainty looms over crucial
International
Aid the words of Judy Weinstein no
jackles peacocks or bombs good start
today how the latest Canadian victim of
hamas's attack is being remembered while
the Devastation grows from Israel's
Siege of Gaza the growing number of
states trying to block Donald Trump's
reelection Ambitions how America's
highest court could weigh in and
advancements and disruptions how AI has
impacted our daily lives this year it's
like being given the gift of fire it can
also burn down whole
societies global national with Donna FZ
reporting tonight Colleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us Ukrainian
President Vladimir zalinski says his
country will respond in the wake of a
massive overnight Russian Air Assault
which has left at least 30 people
[Music]
dead this maternity hospital in the
eastern city of nepro was just one
target of Russia's widest and deadliest
assault since the start of its fullscale
Invasion Ukraine says Russian forces
launched nearly 160 missiles and drones
in the attack last night which impacted
at least six major cities and their
surrounding
regions internationally condemnation has
been Swift including from Canada Defense
Minister Bill Blair saying today
moscow's attack once again demonstrates
the brutality of Putin's Invasion a
message welcomed by Kei but as Redmond
Shannon reports it's one that ukrainians
hope will translate into more support on
the front lines and a warning some of
the images in this report are disturbing
buried alive but this man is one of the
luckier victims of an early morning
barrage of air strikes across Ukraine
the highest number of missile and drone
attacks in one day since Russia's
fullscale Invasion almost 2 years
ago civilian targets hit in major cities
a teacher among the dead in the southern
city of zapara the war may be almost 2
years old but no one can ever get used
to this in nepro a maternity hospital
struck patients and staff heated sirens
and got to a shelter in
time this nurse said the labor Wards
were hit the
hardest a local resident says she heard
the missiles fly past before loud
explosions the capital ke hit two
extensive damage near a warehouse where
at least nine n people were
killed other strikes hit the Black Sea
port of Odessa and the Western city of
Lviv near
Poland across the border the head of
Poland's Armed Forces says one Russian
missile passed into and out of its
airspace other missiles have landed in
the NATO member country during the War
President Vladimir zilinski says Ukraine
will respond as he visited troops in the
Frontline donbass town of adka it is
almost encircled by
Russia these attacks have come as
crucial future us support remains tied
up in Congress the value of air defense
systems illustrated by Ukraine's claims
it shot down 34 of the 158 missiles and
drones Russia has been saving up and
waiting to make this a brutal dark
violent winter for the Ukrainian people
it's only going to get worse they have
been working with Iran to boost their
production of drones the UK says it's
sending more air defense missiles
Ukraine hopes words of support from the
US EU and Canada will translate into
more physical support to Redmond Shannon
Global News
London the family and friends of the
last Canadian taken by Hamas say what
happened to Judy Weinstein is a double
crime first the murder and now the
withholding of her body they calling on
the Canadian government to do more as
more than 100 people are still being
held hostage and as new disturbing
images reveal the growing impact of
Israel's intensified offensive in Gaza
Abigail Bean has the
latest this is Judy speaking from kibot
o and so happens we are now undergoing a
military
operation Judy Weinstein hagi's poetry
is a reflection of her talents and
passion and life close to the the Gaza
border no Jackal peacocks or
bombs good start today her last Haiku
published October 7th the day she and
her husband Gad Hai were captured by
Hamas and the family only just learned
murdered their bodies have not been
released they were really believing and
hopeful that Judy was alive this
beautiful soul this teacher of
mindfulness the rul Wallenberg Center
wants Canada to investigate Hamas
actions in the terror attack of October
7th and Beyond and issue dozens of
sanctions Israel's defense minister says
intensive actions in Gaza will continue
quote until our goals are achieved that
meant fresh air strikes Friday with more
people killed wounded and displaced why
can't we live normally this 13-year-old
lost her home for the second time after
fleeing her first and the thought of me
being killed or my my other brother
being killed just crossing m m
repeatedly people search through Rubble
for survivors here working to free a
child thousands more feared missing or
buried the Hamas ran health authority
said more than 200 people were killed in
strik since Thursday putting the death
toll above 21,000 Hamas does not
distinguish between civilians and
combatants in its numbers there will be
no prisoner swab deal or no negotiations
Under Fire until the Israeli aggression
ends Hamas released video said to show
attacks on Israeli Vehicles the Israeli
military released video said to show a
new deeper tunnel Network discovered in
Northern Gaza that was later destroyed
and in Han Yunis a child's room with
explosives and grenades may we all be
granted the right to our basic rights of
home food
shelter and peaceful days
Judy Weinstein hagy remained hopeful for
peace her family now remembering that
peaceful nature as her poetry lives on
Abigail Bean Global News
Ottawa Police in Ottawa say divers have
recovered the body of a second teenager
who went missing in the city's R River
the boy's body was found late last night
following the earlier discovery of
another boy's body they were among four
teenagers who fell through the ice
Wednesday night one boy and a girl were
able to get to shore in safety before
First Responders arrived in less than a
week at least six Canadians have died
after falling into icy bodies of
water a British Columbia trucking
company has had its entire fleet pulled
off the roads after yet another one of
its trucks slammed into a Metro
Vancouver overpass it comes just two
weeks after the province's government
announced new penalties aimed at
preventing such crashes as nuga reports
SE it's not the only part of of the
country where these dangerous incidents
are happening potentially pointing to a
bigger
issue it is absolutely the driver's
fault putting the blame squarely on the
driver a BC company is under
investigation by the province's
commercial vehicle safety and
enforcement Branch it's basically
insubordination they don't follow
instructions The Province says the
entire fleet of more than 60 trucks at
Chohan Freight forwarders has been
suspended after a flat deck truck
carrying what appears to be heavy
construction material smashed into an
overpass in Delta BC leading to traffic
chaos the company claims an impatient
driver hit the road before getting a
permit and a route plan we have
extensive safety in training protocols
and place screening you know and quite
frankly I think it just boils into
driver lack of common sense but this is
the company's sixth overpass Collision
in 2 years it says the driver was fired
in every instance but the United
truckers Association says it's unfair
for drivers to pay that price adding a
lack of comprehensive training is a big
issue there are also calls for the
province to upgrade overpasses and
increase their height it's not a big
difference but yes if you see the the
overall clearance is in BC is bit lower
than other provinces BC's Transportation
Minister recently announced tougher
penalties and regulations the new fines
for offenses related to over height
loads will more than quadruple to be the
highest in Canada it's an issue across
the country in October Ontario
Provincial Police said a dump truck with
its bin raised struck a bridge overpass
on Highway
404 this Montreal area overpass has been
involved in more than 30 crashes in the
last 2 years and in monton this Subway
overpass has become a truck snagging
hotspot a lack of adequate signage was
one of the issues raised there no one
was seriously hurt in these latest
incidents but Road Safety experts warn
more effective Solutions should be put
in place before that changes Nea Global
News Vancouver Edmonton Police have
begun tearing down the first of several
homeless camps in the city the police
were joined by cleanup Crews social
workers and anti-poverty Advocates who
came to witness the Dismantling in total
eight high-risk camps will be removed
after police warned of gang issues drug
use and Tents Catching Fire authorities
have had to ensure there's enough
shelter space available to accept people
who will be
displaced Aviation giant Boeing is
urging Airlines around the world to
inspect all 737 Max planes for a
possible loose bolt in Rudder Control
Systems the warning comes after one
operator discovered a bolt with a
missing nut during routine maintenance
Boeing says it has delivered more than
1,300 Max planes since 2017 and is
urging they all be inspected by January
10th Air Canada WestJet flare and Lynx
all have the max planes in their fleets
Transport Canada says operators will be
required to report their findings
following
inspections Donald Trump's reelection
hopes under threat coming up why more
states are trying to scratch him off the
presidential primary
ballot
Incredible video from the California
coast today has a rogue wave sent people
running in Ventura similar scenes played
out up and down the coast with waves of
more than 20 ft seen in some communities
injuries have been reported and
officials say multiple rescues have
taken place evacuation orders have been
issued for several communities with the
wave surge expected to last into
Saturday former US president Donald
Trump has suffered another setback in
his quest to return to the White House
late Thursday the state of Maine removed
him from the ballot in the upcoming
Republican presidential primary it comes
after a similar decision by Colorado
last week and other states could soon
follow suit our Washington bureau chief
Jackson prco
reports there's no question he'll keep
campaigning whether voters will actually
find Donald Trump on the ballot is up in
the air after a second state Maine ruled
the former president is ineligible to
run in the Republican primary under the
so-called Insurrection Clause of the US
Constitution I am mindful that no
secretary of state has ever deprived a
presidential candidate of ballot access
and I'm also mindful that no
presidential candidate has ever engaged
in Insurrection under section three of
the 14th Amendment we will never give up
we will never concede it all stems from
Trump's role in the January 6th attack
on the US capital and his attempts to
overturn an election he had lost
Colorado's Supreme Court came to the
same conclusion last week while Michigan
and California have declined to remove
Trump from ballots more than a dozen
other states are still weighing
challenges to Trump's eligibility first
time it's ever happened in American
history much less to a presidential
candidate or to a former presidential
candidate or the front runner for his
party's nomination Trump's campaign
argues any ballot removal amounts to
voter suppression and is politically
motivated the state rulings are headed
straight to the US Supreme Court to see
if they'll stand teeing up a chaotic and
potentially confusing presidential
campaign with primaries just weeks away
both sides in this dispute have asked
the Supreme Court to decide this case
basically immediately uh lightning fast
if the Supreme Court wants to decide
this case it has to do it pretty soon
because these ballots are about to be
printed the longer it takes to settle
the matter the more it may help Trump he
has long claimed to be the victim of
political persecution the letter of the
law may be no match for the power of His
rhetoric the scope of any Supreme Court
ruling will determine if other states
are likely to join in the effort to pull
Trump off the ballot the court could
also settle the question of whether
Trump may be open to additional legal
challenges that could pull him off the
ballot in November's general election
Colleen Jackson prco in Washington
thanks Jackson
still ahead why these exiting MPS are
calling Canada's current political
atmosphere
toxic our next federal election isn't
set to take place until fall 2025 still
several MPS have made their intentions
clear they will not seek another term
with some longtime faces leaving
Parliament Hill in the near future
Global News reached out to some to see
how they feel politics has changed
David bter reports and as difficult as
it was to make a decision to leave my
patients I've never regretted the choice
when Caroline Bennett left her medical
practice and entered politics in 1997 it
was a very different atmosphere than the
one she's leaving 26 years later well
I'm afraid it's been pretty
dramatic and and I think got way worse
Bennett is not alone with exiting MPS of
all major national parties sharing a
similar view I don't think we're stuck
forever in this current toxic atmosphere
but but I would call the current
atmosphere toxic Randall Garrison says
he's managed to forge productive
relationships under Steven Harper
majorities and the current Justin
Trudeau minority his key focus on
committees where he says real work gets
done I think people who who do come here
to uh what I call Yell are important
they create the space for those rest of
us who are actually the doers in the
House of
Commons that's why nearly 4 million
people on X alone in the eyes of some
MPS their colleagues are more focused on
social media than actual debate I think
it's uh it it's it's literally running
the show today and uh I just don't think
that's healthy for
democracy Ron leer has spent the last 50
years in and out of Politics the Alberta
conservative was once Premier Peter laah
he's press secretary and says he's
noticed fewer business people Advocates
and professionals entering politics
you've got a lot of young staffers who
are now members of parliament that's not
to say they're not good members of
parliament but I don't think they bring
that broad range of experience that you
used to see in cabinets in caucus 10 20
years ago the leader of the
conservatives is demonstrating this week
that he just can't tell the truth to
Canadians so leper sees this and the
ratcheted up nature of social media
debate as contributing factors to the
deepen partisan divides tell the truth
to Canadians a byelection still needs to
be called to choose Bennett successor
and the former physician can't help but
worry that the quote spectacle and
circus will keep good people from
seeking office I do think that we have
to put a more human face on on being a
parliamentarian I'm worried that good
people won't run and that we actually
need that is the foundation of our
democracy that good people would run for
office David bter Global News
Ottawa next the increasing impact of AI
on our daily lives and where the
technology is headed in
[Music]
2024 3 2 1 engine full power and lift
off SpaceX capped off the year with two
rocket launches last night bringing its
total number of blast offs to 98 this
year the first launch was filled with
mystery as the US military secretive x37
B space plane once again took off adding
to the more than 10 years in orbit it's
already logged since its debut in 2010
the second consisted of a Falcon 9
rocket launching 23 starlink satellites
into low earth
orbit well from smartphones and atome
assistance to the workplace artificial
intelligence already touches our daily
lives but whether it's For Better or For
Worse depends on who you ask Mike Dray
takes a look at the Technology's impact
over the last year and how it could
shape our
future the robots powered by artificial
intelligence work for us well for now
that's an AI joke by the way or is it
because the lines between what is and
isn't powered by AI are getting
blurry
okay got my clock it's no longer
theoretical this AI pin was designed to
replace our smartphones no apps no
screen just camera projector and the
ability to answer virtually any question
this is $28
online great buy it so if we thought
smart assistants were smart they weren't
once they get AI in their brains though
they're going to be almost as smart as
we are AI is inescapable with your phone
you'll be able to alter images or
isolate audio or create your own Clone
Army to do your bidding all right I made
that last part up but I didn't do this
AI did
a similar program was used to clean up
40-year-old recordings by John lennin
Long thought unusable giving Beatles
fans something new what's also new is
how 25% of Canadians have found a way to
use generative AI in their jobs and that
number is expected to increase
dramatically if 2023 was our first
exposure to the technology where we just
played with it a little bit 2024 is
going to be when uh it starts to
integrate with the tools that we use
every
day chat GPT opened the door to Everyday
Ai and now the Giants of techer
sprinting through it in what's become an
arms race to develop the definitive AI
platform for home and Business alike
expect to hear a lot about Microsoft's
co-pilot Google's Gemini and meta AI in
2024 platforms that are already being
integrated into the Technologies we use
like technology is a tool it's like
being given the gift of Fire fire is a
wonderful thing can you know cook your
meals and give you warmth but can also
burn down whole societies if it sounds
like Pandora's Box brimming with hope
but with the potential to create chaos
well it is AI has made the phenomenon
known as deep fakes widely accessible
allowing anybody to manipulate images
and audio and that could impact
elections there's also a fear AI will
eliminate all kinds of jobs including in
journalism you can hear us and see our
lips moving this newscast may seem real
but it's all AI including the anchors
and reporters Sports Illustrated took a
lot of heat and had to apologize to its
readers because it tried to pass off AI
generated content as if it had been
produced by humans it's the only reason
that it was discovered is when people
looked up the authors they couldn't
actually find these people in real life
so if that investigation hadn't been
done people would assume those articles
were done by humans 2024 is shaping up
to be a big year for AI full of promise
and anxiety Mike Dr Global News
Toronto I'm definitely real you can
trust me that's global national for this
Friday night I'm Colleen chrisy
tonight's your Canada is Portal BR
Newland and Labrador we love to see your
Canada please email it to viewers
global.com thanks for watching Sophie
Louie will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow have a good
night
[Music]
n